hey everybody Doug Walker here I just
saw Aquaman sorry it took a little bit
to get to this came out on Christmas so
like three big movies came out on
Christmas and I'm maybe because of my
job I don't usually see movies around
Christmas time you know cuz I I see them
all the time uh you know I want
Christmas just be my friends and family
but a lot of people go see movies on
Christmas they like sharing that
experience you know cool um I usually
don't have time so three big movies came
out one was Mary Poppins which came out
before this because I really wanted to
see I'll come him first but I came out
first like a day before so now I've seen
this one and I'm gonna try and see
bumblebee believe it or not not because
I had much interests of the transformer
movies anymore but I have a friend in it
John Bailey that the eyes trailer guy
epic voice guy he's in it he's
technically two of the Transformers I
like supporting my friends so if you go
see it if I haven't seen it yes I'm
gonna try and get to that too
blah blah blah talk about Aquaman um
let's give really good reviews a lot of
people are liking it and shit if you
were to tell me like out of the DC
Universe that the two superheroes that
wouldn't get very good movies were
Batman and Superman and the ones who
would get the best movies are Wonder
Woman Aquaman I'd be like what Universal
Michael yeah this was a lot of fun I
have a blast with this movie it's not
perfect but I mean like this is like the
closest to like a big epic DC movie like
I feel like they just went to James 1
and they're like okay your big hit
director and everything I mean we don't
want to be a horror film or anything I
know you probably want brand Chad so uh
just give us a good superhero movie I
mean it's Aquaman I know that's tough
it's the guy that talks to fish and
everything but you know just me do
something with it uh you know when we
got Drago that'll help you know he's
pretty cool so you know just do
something within he's like yeah cool I
want to make Lord of the Rings so that's
what he did he did this big Lord of the
Rings epic and he's not bad
it's actually hugely entertaining and it
feels big it looks big you know we saw
this on IMAX just because we couldn't
find a time for the standard screen I
was just like oh I don't I don't need to
see Aquaman on IMAX I don't need I am so
glad I did this looked amazing this was
just like one of the best looking films
I've seen all year and that's it's a
good year of like good-looking films uh
so I mean it's the story is very I want
to say basic but but like you've kind of
heard it before
it's the long-lost you know the person
who was born who shouldn't have been
born has a connection to like greatness
in this case it's like a royal family
and he doesn't think he's anything he's
in between worlds but now something bad
is gonna happen that's gonna affect the
world he came from and the world he's in
and that's going to you know set
everything a blunder cuz everything's
gonna blow up or whatever so now he has
to go back and redeem himself but he's
not ready so he has to go on this big
journey with this person he doesn't get
along with but it's probably gonna get
along with by the end some connection to
his parents some connection to some
device or devices that he has to find
you've heard this a million times that's
not the strength of the movie honestly
if you showed me this script I'd be like
well there's some cool things in here
but come on you got it you got a scale
scale some of this back and I the
problem that the problem I do have it is
long it is such a long movie I mean it
felt like it was three hours when we
look at the running time it was like
kind of close in like I don't know I got
a factor in previews and everything but
it felt long and every time they're
gonna go do something else it's like oh
Christ do we have to but then when we
got there it was always fun it was
always entertaining and I think a lot of
that is the main actor is a very
enjoyable Aquaman
very different I haven't read Aquaman
growing up but I I know what he looks
like I have a general idea about his
power
it doesn't seem that interesting to me
but they they made them a lot of fun in
this I mean getting the guy who played
Rago but that's really cool that's a
cool actor um and just the the wide
scale of this I mean Atlantis in this
looks amazing I mean all the shots in
this some of the circling shots get the
the you know there's a prison here the
camera like circles around it that gets
a little old after a while but they they
still look really nice and there's
probably a little bit of like the
exposition stuff where somebody would be
like well now we have to do this why
well let me go into the grand story blah
blah blah and there's a lot of that well
now we have to get this thing what's
that thing well let me go into the grand
story oh so there's there's a lot of
that and it does feel like exposition
but it's such beautiful looking
exposition and the actors are so
dedicated to it and they're just so in
this world and they're they're saying it
like they're in the Lord of the Rings
movie I mean now with that comes kind of
the goofy comedy and not every scene
works and again who feels long but uh by
the end you kind of felt like you saw
this big big movie uh it didn't feel
like it was about much and that you know
again you've seen this kind of story
millions of times but it's just the the
scale of it and the way it was shot and
the way they act in everyone treated it
so seriously but not to a fault not to a
point where you're like okay lighten up
because because there are funnier
moments and the main character is kind
of a you know he cracks one-liners and
stuff and the Percy's traveling which he
can't does the same thing she does I
have faith with them so she makes fun of
them and stuff and yeah even the opening
the waves parents meet I mean it's this
lighthouse attendant Nao's guy looks
after a white house and like the queen
of atlantis and they form this
relationship and they're learning about
their two worlds and it's funny and it's
cute and it's charismatic and you really
like them
so yeah the action is a lot of fun in it
it's it's a very distinct style which I
found interesting like I think it works
here I think she kind of stopped
here you know cuz the the way it's kind
of done there are a lot of shots that
kind of go on and on like seeing if they
can do it in one shot which clearly they
use computers to break it up and stuff
but there's also again kind of that
circling really wide angle lens way of
doing things where they'll kind of get
really close to a person then back up
and then circle around and go over here
it's a person flies they'll follow him
and then circle back the other way they
try to do these really super wide angle
one take shots which again I mean I feel
like a computer broke it up in certain
scenes but they're mostly done good but
I don't want to see it to be like a
continuing thing or if they're gonna do
it they have to add more to it cuz here
it's like great now I feel like if I saw
that the exact same thing another movie
I'd be sick of it but the actual stunts
are great the underwater scenes they
well they don't look real they look
great there's I was kind of wondering
how you gonna do this underwater world I
mean first of all it's gotta be super
expensive because a lot of stuff not
surprisingly as underwater in this
somehow they work in the desert I don't
know how they did that but but that's it
not even like you know half the movie I
mean a lot of it is underwater and again
it doesn't look like wow it's really
there but it just looks so gorgeous and
so beautiful and everybody moves so
elegantly that you just kind of go you
know this is just beautiful I'm diggin
it I just think it looks fantastic
um the so yeah even kind of like the
swimming around there's times it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense I think you
kind of know that going into a comic
book movie like it's not gonna be like
you know they start off this one fight
it kind of came in the middle of the
movie I think it's like near the end of
the first act maybe but you know the
main villain who's a good main villain
in this to it have very dignified and
very strong or interesting you know he's
fighting Aquaman here and they're
fighting like on the ground
you know like walk around and they shoot
into the air and they start fighting at
the air the water I guess and they start
swimming around I was just like well why
why did it start with them on
crowd how does that even work but that's
that comic books so it's kind of that
weird movement where sometimes they'll
walk around just like they're people but
then they'll you know like project I
don't like a super fart the water I
can't be the first one to say that but
it it's this cool thing where it's
almost like a rocket pack that kind of
go like this and boom like something
almost shoots from their feet and they
go across the water and it's cool it
just looks like they're farting sorry
that's tell me someone else's made that
joke alright anyway it might be only
mature bass I don't care so alright so
you got this beautiful world is this
beautiful it can looks like the avatar
better looking avatar in my opinion and
you have this again this very typical
plot but we just likeable actors who are
really dedicated some decent enough
character writing I I feel like this
this could have felt like too much
exposition this Coffelt like too much
going from place to place and everything
but every and it does a little bit but
every time it starts to they add
something cool they add something neat
like there's just enough of a spin on it
or just enough new stuff on to make it
like really fun and with that said I
feel like there are gonna be people that
watch this and they're just gonna be
like this was way too much for you know
kind of a run-of-the-mill story even
though it's a it's a run-of-the-mill
epic story you know it's like you've
heard these a lot of epics it's like
what Eragon tried to do the movie I've
never read the book but but like what
the movie tried to do it's like god
we've seen this so many times and
there's nothing new where with this
there is a lot of new stuff and
impressive stuff and visually stunning
stuff in it so I think there are gonna
be people they're gonna be like there's
just too much going on in this and in
terms of character and story they're not
adding too many new elements and it's
fair enough I can see that especially
when the film goes as long as it does uh
and that is a problem but for me like
they always they always just
added some sort of new twist or some
sort of cool visual or some sort of
interesting thing about the world or a
funny one line there are the characters
are just likeable enough but if you were
to give me this script like you know no
production designs or anything just the
script that belie lucky this one guy is
haunting him because you know uncle
MELAS father died you could cut him out
they have to go to like five places to
find this device that's gonna like bring
them all the power you could cut out
like three of those places you know I'd
be looking at the script and say chop
that chop that chop that uh and yeah you
could but there's so I don't know the
screenwriters or the director or
whatever months I just looked at this
and saw a possibility it's like no
weekend I want this to feel epic and in
epics they got to go to various places
you know lore the Rings Zelda you know a
lot of these quest stories so I feel
like it worked just enough and the
characters and the acting we're strong
enough and the visuals were so amazing
and the action was entertaining that I
really had a good time and I was
squirming in my seat every once in a
while but when but then something cool
would happen and I just fell in love
with it so yeah it's man in terms of the
DC movies I guess I think yeah I think
it's still like Wonder Woman more Wonder
Woman had a little bit more character
and she was a bit more interesting but
it Mia really had that epic sighs it
really had this huge scale where when a
battle was happening like it felt like a
big battle I was shot like an epic
battle like there's some real Return of
the King scenes in here that if you're
gonna see it see it on IMAX I mean you
will like with this way if you see it
you don't see it on IMAX you're gonna be
kicking yourself you're gonna be like
dammit why didn't I pay the extra a
couple of dollars or whatever because
yeah it is really amazing to look at it
is it really is one of those spectacle
movies in my opinion where it's like I
said it doesn't look realistic but it
looks amazing it's just this phenomenal
looking film and you're behind it you
don't want to see the bad guy take
but you also understand where the bad
guys coming from you want to see aquaman
win you're following him on the journey
and you like the guy and he's funny and
he's the arc he has to go through is you
know typical but it's still a good arc
you feel like yet this guy would be
thinking this at this point and maybe
you would too you know like he's really
charming enough I almost feel like this
is the second real Thor movie we got
because the first one my opinions
writing Iraq but Ragnarok really had a
life story you know and that was part of
the fun this one has like even though
it's kind of standard it is a heavier
story and I feel like the the directing
and the acting and the visuals just
really cemented as something really
large really a lot of fun so uh yeah
this is out of I mean granted you should
probably know I'm not huge fan but DC
movies that have come out but yeah I
feel like out of all of them this this
is probably the second best one I mean
just a solid fun movie I feel like
there's gonna be people they're gonna
think it's too much and fair enough
that's completely understandable but I
really thought I dug this movie a lot I
just had a blast I could maybe see it
again and like I said the length is
tough but it's like I will definitely
buy it on blu-ray I'm gonna watch a lot
of these scenes over turns to see it on
the big screen like I might which I
don't save for a lot of movies like I
did see spider-verse again that's
another one if you told me out of all
the spider-man movies the one where like
this anime girl is spider-man and
Nicolas Cage is a film noir spider-man
and all these parallel universes that's
only designed to get all this into Meg
universe is going from Sony would be the
best spider-man that came out this year
to I'd be like what the hell so this
year at least in terms of like some of
these comic book movies has really been
a surprise and I'm really happy about it
because even though the Marvel films are
still going strong and it's still really
entertaining I feel like these other
movies they've had such a history of
trying to catch up to what Marvel is
doing are now
doing things so different and so unique
and so entertaining that kinda
surpassing Marvel and don't get me wrong
it's only one or two fellow Sony head
into the spy reverse DC had you know
Wonder Woman but that's its debate on
whether or not it's better than some of
the Marvel movies might be yeah I did
what I definitely look through them all
but with Aquaman I mean I feel like this
is really a change of pace for DC and
just what a random movie to do it with
maybe that's why maybe because you know
people know Aquaman but like if you're
ask someone what's Aquaman's backstory
then name five of the characters from
his comic like the common person
probably couldn't do it so maybe there's
a little bit more freedom with it kind
of the same thing with you know Wonder
Woman a lot of people know Wonder Woman
they can name maybe two or three other
characters from the comic you know but
but not much more
a same thing with a spider-man the Miles
character you know like a fair amount
people know the Miles character but not
too many know the others so maybe
because there's not that weight of
familiarity they feel like they can kind
of have more fun with her they don't
have to be too bound by it they can
really expand and try new stuff and I
feel like even though it is like I said
a standard story they're trying this
epic size thing and I just I can't
believe the amount of money they threw
at this - for Aquaman maybe they just
knew his popularity was growing and they
just you know the Wonder Woman did
really well so they're like okay we
gotta try like the epic size stuff the
big grand lands you know the the giant
whirls the royalty the king the Queen
that have to go and you know have the
child that's gonna save the day and you
know that kind of traditional epic story
so yeah you know that's another thing -
it didn't feel like it was trying to
connect to the other DC films I'm trying
to even think of like any point maybe
one or two times they mentioned Justice
League but they never say Batman they
never say Superman like they don't
mention any of that and yeah it it was
really strong for and
like says fight reverse mentioned all
sorts of different spider-man's and
cinematic universes and that's fine too
they did it very cleverly so I don't
know it's way it's the first time in a
while even though once the end game I am
still excited to see the other Marvel
properties coming out it's the first
time in a while where it's like wow like
even though DC is only had you know kind
of one I guess two with Wonder Woman two
really big you know different kind of
films and the Sony said one with spider
first like I'm I mean I'm more excited
what those two are gonna do in the
future now as opposed to Marvel which
don't get me wrong
Marvel's cool I'm gonna watch that I'm
still excited but I feel like where
they're taking they're still evolving
Marvel is evolving these two properties
just through the randomness and I'm
really experimenting and trying new
stuff are kind of taking bigger leaps
because they're taking bigger risks I
feel like in terms of what they're gonna
show like I said who would throw this
much money into Aquaman to make it this
grant and all the directors known for
horror you know I mean he is a big hit
with a lot of the horror films but I
mean like he I wouldn't think I wouldn't
think this guy would be like the
pinnacle Aquaman director and he did a
really great job and I kind of want to
see him do more epic movies honestly I
want to see what he does with more
action films it this is prime my
favorite James Watt I like your sort of
films like I always because there's
gonna be something new and something
creepy but I never have like one that
was great from beginning to end in my
opinion but I do I do like his movies
like just enough this is the first one
where I'm like that was awesome I want
to see more of this so yeah that's about
it
I I really enjoyed this it's like I said
it's so weird to have a year where it's
like Ivan seemed really any ban Marvel
movies or anything but I'm like I'm
excited for to see what DC is gonna do
and what Sony's gonna do I can't believe
I'm saying that you know I like I'm
legitimately like oh I can't wait I
can't wait so yeah I say check it out if
you are gonna see it see it on IMAX it
got please see it on IMAX I didn't see
it in 3d I think they have it in 3d um
the shots are pretty fast in a lot of
the action see
so I don't know how that would work but
it try it out me maybe it'll maybe
they'll be good but definitely if you're
gonna see it see it on IMAX like it is
worth the money to see it there so guys
that's about it I had a blast I can't
wait to see what's coming up next I
can't believe I'm excited for Aquaman 2
this is so weird
so yeah that's about it I'll see you
later
take care
you